an FBI informant says Russia routed
millions of dollars to the u.s. in an
effort to buy influence with the Obama
administration and with Bill and Hillary
Clinton chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge explains Fox News
confirms that an FBI informant who has
not gone public spent four hours
Wednesday answering questions from
staffers on the Senate Judiciary as well
as House Oversight and intelligence
committees their focus is an Obama
administration deal that allowed a
Russian nuclear energy agency to gain a
controlling stake in uranium 1 a
canadian-based company with mining
interests in the western US
Russians stole my client in early 2010
that the the fix was in
it was a shoe-in ton Singh who is the
FBI informants lawyer says the Russians
laid the groundwork after Bill Clinton
and Frank Giustra a wealthy Canadian
philanthropist and investor in uranium 1
went to Kazakhstan in 2006 in a
statement Giustra said he later sold his
stake before the deal went through and
18 months before Hillary Clinton became
Secretary of State
by 2010 tun Singh insists the Russians
made their move when Hillary Clinton
became Secretary of State that is when
the Russians just really went to town
and said hey we can go in there with our
influence with the Clintons and we're
going to get this uranium one business
done as Secretary of State Clinton did
none of the final saying the deal
considered by the committee on foreign
investment in the United States required
approval from nine different agencies
but critics point to a $500,000 speaking
fee for Bill Clinton and multi-million
dollar donations to the Clinton
Foundation from Giustra as payback for
facilitating the deal hillary clinton
denied the allegations in a radio
interview with WABC i had nothing to do
with the decision it was delegated to
somebody else in the State Department
and nine people had to agree and they
all agreed from all the different
agencies in our government and then two
Republican governors had to agree her
office went further in a statement
calling the story a secret informant
charade and along with the FBI text
messages and Republican drafted
surveillance memo a trifecta of GOP
manufactured scandals designed to
distract
from the president's problems and the
threat to democracy he poses the senior
Democrat says the FBI briefed lawmakers
they had lost confidence in the FBI
informant and his credibility
Republicans say their work continues and
pointed the ongoing Justice Department
investigation into the Clinton
Foundation and pay-to-play allegations
Chris Catherine thank you